again things are a little different
today uh Matt Gourley not with us
um I think he's doing something very
important really no he's probably just
buying a
new colored rocks for his aquarium uh
but we are sitting here with David
hoppin who helps out on the show and you
you fill in very nicely uh on the
program from time oh thank you yeah and
uh what's on your mind David no we were
just talking before this did we ever
tell you about the time that someone and
I just abandoned you and Jeff to go to
every single friend's filming location
yeah wait I don't know what you're
talking about whenever first of all you
guys are supposed to take care of myself
and Jeff Ross our executive producer
yeah and and you said that you you both
because you're each the backup for the
other yeah you're the pilot and the
co-pilot yes when both of you leave the
cockpit
that breaks every FAA rule in the book
yeah so what happened where did you go
we just left and uh we were at Warner
Brothers where they filmed friends well
um I mean it's important to have the
context that that week you you made me
watch 56 hours of friends this really is
your fault so this is time it was a part
of a challenge it came up on the show
and we had a challenge to see uh if you
could watch every as many episodes of
friends as possible in one week because
kind of also to prove the point that you
didn't do a lot of actual work okay well
you know you were watching those shows
anyway so that was the best show that
was the bit you're doing it for the show
okay so you watch all these episodes of
friends and then what happened so we we
tape Monday through Thursday I watched
Friends that whole week and then on
Friday you know David used to be a tour
guide on the Warner Brothers lot and
that's where friends was shot yeah so we
were like let's go to all the locations
that friends shot on the Warner Brothers
lot so you went to where the fountain
was yeah we went to the yeah that was at
the ranch like what like a mile or two
away yeah so we left YouTube and then we
took a full tour of the ranch while we
were there
wait so you left your job and I remember
this we didn't tell either of you either
we didn't tell was I doing a show that
day there was no show no it was Friday
yeah it was not even a day so relaxed
yeah no no no no no no no no no no
you're getting a paycheck you should be
on hand to take care of me I probably
needed some valuable uh medical help
that day well that's Norm every day
though
David let's not get it out there that I
have a series of fits and convulsions
uh-huh uh pretty much hourly no one
needs to know that what um so you went
off did you feel any guilt be honest no
we had a great time we had so much fun
yeah we took sona's car over to The
Fountains yeah the new car or the old
crappy one
I think you had just gotten the new one
I got my it was a new my Kia it was Kia
Zadora yeah we took her to to the ranch
so even if you guys needed us right away
we weren't close to you so we had left
and we had left for like hour did you
have your pager on you
pager
you've always been obsessed with this I
always wish the pager would come back
why because I don't like you know people
can easily you know ignore their phone
but I think both of you should have to
have a 1978 Motorola pager no it's
trapped to your hip yeah
and it would I would use it all the time
I don't like it yeah I feel like you
would use it for nothing serious and
then we would just never return your
calls because it was not expect it to be
real I have to return my calls so anyway
that's uh that's quite a revelation you
left for a day yeah to go look at places
where they shot Friends episodes well
and then we we filmed it and then we
spent even more time editing the footage
that we got into like a little post that
we put on Instagram then we put it up on
Instagram and then Instagram was like
you can't use the Friends theme
immediately so then we had to record the
Friends theme and then we edited that on
top of the footage that was you did this
all in a day when you were are
supposedly working in our defense no I'm
sorry you have the work ethic of an
alcoholic chimp if you gave a circus
monkey alcohol
and then monitored his work progress
throughout the day as he stumbled and
bumbled his it's unbelievable you you're
the one who ate made me watch
so many hours of friends that week so
you know
they're like enabling me if I'm an
alcoholic chimp you're the the chimp guy
who's giving me out guy he's the chimp
trainer okay you're the chimp trainer
and you're just like have some more
alcohol chimp and then it's you're the
problem you're the problem oh nothing
not nothing nothing you did is what
you're saying nothing that David arrived
I think it's important to note that you
didn't know that this happened so
clearly it was fine
where were you that's not wait a minute
you can as I said I'll stick with this
analogy if the pilot and the co-pilot
both leave the cockpit and go and start
getting high in the men's room no one on
the plane knows about it but it's still
a crime
you did endangered everybody no
endangered in danger yeah what you had
to answer your phone yeah you had to get
your own yeah what a Spielberg called
then what you would have looked really
cool at answering your own phone you
don't need an assistant you're Conan
O'Brien I mean I'm I'm a big Wheeler
Dealer I have some pretty big phone
calls come through don't I Sona not at
all we you know they're finished the
whole days where we will be sitting and
no one will call I'm sure not I don't
never really never there's there was
never a time where I thought oh no what
if we're missing an important phone call
Jesus never we gotta get back to that
desk ASAP it was never come on big time
Big name directors never called
did they even have a record number what
are you talking about I don't I'm I'm
just curious what about like rap
producers or people in the music
industry they might be trying to call me
for what
to get my take I'm I'm a
Legend to get it you don't even know
anybody who's doing music right now do
you I mean I know we talked about and
you keep naming the same people over and
over but like you know yeah
you don't like big pop stars I feel like
you can't
I feel like you don't know Conan Gray
because you took my name name a song
that he's saying I wish I was the real
Conan okay
that guy he must burn his ass that
people were always running up to him
going I love you I love you Conan and
then he turns around they're like oh
Conan gray not Conan O'Brien guys don't
even look alike I love that people at
least just because he hasn't seen name
people think that he's me stupid
yes
oh no
not the Conan who's tearing up the
charts who's really relevant not the
gorgeous young all right take it easy
Conan gray if I had work done
um anyway I know exactly what's going on
Conan gray
um
so quick
silly
[Laughter]
this is like you trying to name Taylor
Swift albums that's rough
uh well anyway I do think that I should
dock you a day's pay both for what you
did oh okay was this how many years ago
was this uh it had to have been like
four or five four five years ago yeah I
don't remember it's going to be adjusted
too for inflation
um I don't think that's gonna happen do
you even know how much we get paid I'm
not sure I didn't think you get paid
money I know you get beans right you get
what we told you was magical beans and
you keep saying I'm home to Illinois
yeah nothing's happened with them don't
you worry Mama these These are magic
beans yeah
Conan says they're magical beings put
them with the other beans
just a big bowl of beans yeah no those
things accrue over time though but you
actually pay me money so thanks all
right listen for that uh this was a huge
waste of time
uh when gorley gets back he's gonna be
stunned by what happened in his absence
um but I'm proud of both of you I know I
give you a hard time
but you really are great at what you do
what I'm waiting for it nope I really
are both valuable people mean a lot to
me so there you go
and yeah here it comes nope no sure as
my name is Conan gray you were the two
best
people I've ever met